aquí tenemos 6 fracciones diferentes y
me gustaría mucho que que intentara
hacerlos entonces ponle pausa al vídeo e
intenta escribir cada una de estas
fracciones como un decimal aunque ya en
este momento yo asumo que ya lo hiciste
ya lo intentaste y así que vamos con la
primera fracción esta fracción 34 sobre
10 a que es equivalente sabemos que 34
sobre 10 puede ser interpretado como 34
dividido entre 10 cierto así que 34 y
aquí va un punto decimal que siempre
está ahí implícitamente siempre está ese
punto decimal podemos también poner
ceros
entonces ok cuando dividimos entre 10
vamos a mover el punto decimal un
espacio a la izquierda y el resultado
será menor un número menor y ok si
estuviéramos multiplicando lo veríamos a
la derecha pero estamos dividiendo así
que lo movemos un espacio a la izquierda
entonces cuando hacemos esto movera el
punto decimal una vez a la izquierda
vamos a obtener un número más pequeño 34
se va a convertir en 3.4
y tiene total sentido porque porque si
multiplicamos 3.4 por 10mo veríamos el
decimal a la derecha un espacio y
obtendríamos el resultado anterior que
es 34 así que 3.4 es el resultado
vamos con 7 sobre 10 ok es la misma idea
esto es lo mismo esto es lo mismo que 7
dividido entre 10 esa línea horizontal
significa es lo mismo que dividirlo
entonces cuando dividimos esto cuando
hacemos la división el punto decimal se
va a mover a la izquierda un espacio
entonces quedaría así obtenemos puntos 7
puntos 7 o lo que es lo mismo 0.7 ajá
por lo tanto 7 sobre 10 y 7 dividido
entre 10 es igual a 0.7 es nuestro
resultado ahora vamos con 53 sobre 100
53 sobre 100 puede ser otra vez
interpretado como 53 dividido
entre 100 y aquí voy a poner un punto
decimal que está siempre escrito a
implícitamente entonces estamos
dividiendo entre 100 o lo que es lo
mismo dividir entre 10 por 10 porque 10
por 10 es igual a 100 entonces cuando
estamos dividiendo entre 100 movemos el
punto decimal dos espacios a la
izquierda eso nos va a llevar a 0.53
ahora vamos con 2 sobre 100
ok 2 sobre 100 esto nuevamente puede ser
visto como 2 dividido entre 100 así que
iniciamos con un 2 el 2 y le pongo el
punto decimal ahí vamos a dividir entre
10 2 veces si lo hacemos una vez vamos a
mover el punto decimal una vez a la
izquierda y a la segunda vez que lo
movamos o vemos que no hay nada ahí que
vamos a hacer porque aquí no hay nada
entonces lo que hacemos simplemente es
poner un cero no hay problema y movemos
otra vez el punto decimal recuerda cada
vez que mueves el decimal significa que
estás dividiendo entre 10 así que aquí
estás dividiendo entre 10 y acá también
estás dividiendo entre 10
y vivir entre diez dos veces es lo mismo
que dividir entre 100 porque 10 por 10
es igual a 100 así que 2 sobre 100 es
igual esto es igual a 0.02 y ya lo
habíamos visto antes intentábamos leer
esto este 2 está en el lugar de las
centésimas esto es 2 centésimas y lo
vemos acá también así que 0.2 es el
resultado ahora vamos con 1.098 sobre
esto otra vez es lo mismo que mil 98
dividido entre 100 mil 98 dividido entre
100 iniciamos con 1.098 el punto decimal
está implícitamente aquí pero lo vamos a
mover dos espacios a la izquierda porque
estamos estamos dividiendo entre 100 así
que esto nos va a llevar a 10.98 y tiene
total total sentido porque obtuvimos un
valor significantemente más pequeño
cuando lo estamos dividiendo entre 100
ahora vamos con este 9 1967 dividido
entre 1000 y el punto decimal está
implícitamente ahí escrito mil es lo
mismo que 10 x 10 x 10 así que cuando
dividimos entre 1000 estamos dividiendo
entre 10 3 veces ajá por lo tanto vamos
a mover el punto decimal tres veces a la
izquierda y obtenemos 9.967 es lo mismo
que nueve mil 967 sobre sobre 1000 es lo
mismo que 9.967 o nueve y 967 milésimas
y ya está como puedes ver es sencillo
estar dividiendo entre entre múltiplos
de 10 entonces bueno espero te haya
servido nos vemos pronto
bye